por aquí tenemos tres series diferentes
y lo que quiero que hagas es para usar
el vídeo y pensar si cada una de ellas
converge o diverge bien vamos a trabajar
juntos primero recordemos si a pesar de
que estamos sumando una cantidad
infinita de términos en todos estos
casos obtenemos un valor finito para esa
suma infinita de términos entonces
decimos que la serie converge y siempre
lo encuentro sorprendente que la serie
sea divergente significa que no
obtenemos un valor finito de esa suma
infinita de todos los términos así que
como podemos saberlo bueno ya sabemos
algo sobre series geométricas y éstas se
ven un poco como series geométricas así
que recordemos que sabemos al respecto
sabemos que la forma estándar de
escribir una serie geométrica es empezar
en n ok
bueno normalmente empezamos en n igual a
0 pero vamos a decir que empezamos en
alguna constante acá y vamos a ir hasta
infinito de a por ere elevado a la n
donde r es nuestra razón común ya hemos
profundizado sobre esto en otros vídeos
esta es la forma estándar de escribir
una serie geométrica ya sabemos que es
el valor absoluto de r está entre 0 y 1
entonces la serie converge
de lo contrario la serie divergen
por lo tanto tal vez sea una buena idea
que intentemos reescribir estas
expresiones que definen cada uno de
nuestros términos a medida que
incrementamos n
sí podemos reescribir las de esta forma
podremos identificar la razón común y
pensar si convergen o no por lo tanto
enfoquémonos en esta parte de aquí e
intentemos reescribir la
veamos 5 elevado a la n 1 podemos
escribir lo como 5 elevado a la n por 5
elevado a la menos 1 y esto multiplica a
9 decimos elevado a la n iv podemos
escribir esto como primero 5 elevado a
la menos 1 es lo mismo que un quinto por
y después tengo 5 elevado a la n por 9
décimos elevado a la n como tenemos el
mismo exponente y estamos multiplicando
todo entonces podemos cambiar el orden
entonces esto es lo mismo que 5 por 9
décimos
todo esto elevado a la n iv esto será
igual a un quinto x
y bueno 9 por 5 45 entonces nos queda 45
entre 10 que es 4.5 4.5 elevado a la n
por lo tanto para que quede todo en
orden
podemos reescribir nuestra serie
original como empezaremos en n igualados
y vamos hasta infinito de un quinto por
4.5 elevado a la n
entonces cuál es nuestra razón común
cuál es el valor de r podemos ver
claramente que es 4.5 y el valor
absoluto de 4.5 no está entre 0 y 1
por lo tanto aseguramos que la serie
diverge ahora bien si has encontrado
este procedimiento inspirador y si no
pudiste hacerlo la primera vez que te
pedí que pausar hasta el vídeo
intentarlo de nuevo
pausa el vídeo e intenta trabajar por tu
cuenta con estas series ahora que ya
viste un ejemplo ok
vayamos a la siguiente intentemos
manipular algebraica mente esta parte
para llevarla a esta forma así que vamos
a hacerlo podemos escribir esto veamos
si podemos obtener algunas cosas
elevadas sólo a la potencia n
podemos escribirlo como tres medios esto
elevado la potencia n y podemos escribir
esta parte de aquí como 1 entre 9
elevado a la n por 9 elevado al cuadrado
y esto será igual a tres medios elevado
a la n iv veamos podemos factorizar o
pasar al frente a 1 entre 9 al cuadrado
así que vamos a hacerlo nos queda 1
entre 81 que es esta parte de aquí 1
entre 81 por tres medios elevado a la n
por 1 entre 9 elevado a la n pero 1
entre 9 elevado a la n es lo mismo que
un noveno elevado a la n iv ahora
tenemos dos expresiones la potencia n
así que podemos hacer lo mismo que
hicimos en el ejemplo anterior esto va a
ser lo mismo que 1 entre 81 x
tres medios por un noveno
todo esto elevado a la n sólo estamos
aplicando las propiedades de los
exponentes por aquí esto va a ser igual
a 1 entre 81 x y veamos tres medios por
un noveno es lo mismo que 3 entre 18 que
es lo mismo que un sexto entonces nos
quedará 1 entre 81 por un sexto elevado
a la n así que podemos reescribir
nuestra serie original como la suma
desde n igual a 5 hasta infinito de 1
entre 81 por un sexto elevado a la n iv
por lo tanto claramente un sexto es
nuestra razón común y su valor absoluto
en efecto está entre 0 y 1 por lo tanto
en esta situación la serie converge
berge
ahora vayamos al último ejemplo lo vamos
a hacer un poco más rápido veamos
vamos a intentar manipular algebraica
mente esta parte esta parte será lo
mismo que 2 elevado a la n por 1 entre 3
elevado a la n por 3 elevado a la menos
uno y esto será igual a 2 elevado a la n
por 1 entre 3 elevado a la n por 1 entre
3 elevado a la menos uno que es lo mismo
que 1 entre un tercio que es lo mismo
que 3 esto será lo mismo que si ponemos
al 3 al frente tenemos 3 por 2 elevado a
la n por y bueno tengo uno entre 13
elevado a la n que es lo mismo que un
tercio elevado a la n así que esto será
igual a 3
dos por un tercio esto elevado a la n y
esto es lo mismo que 3 x
dos tercios elevado a la n
así que reescribimos esta parte de aquí
como tres por dos tercios elevado a la n
podemos ver que nuestra razón común es
dos tercios y el valor absoluto de dos
tercios claramente está entre 0 y 1 así
que una vez más esta serie converge
convergen y hemos acabado